avec ce documentaire réalisé par
Dorothée Fresno et Benoît Russell vous
l'avez compris à l'allure vont les
choses le diabète concernera bientôt un
individu sur 10 sur la planète et elle a
vu de cette enquête dans ce paysage
sanitaire plus qu'à l'armant seul
l'industrie pharmaceutique semble
prospérer allègrement qu'est-ce qui ne
tourne pas ronde dans ce monde du
diabète et que deviennent les malades
dans tout cela et bien nous allons
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présentes sur ce plateau de débat doc en
commençant par vous Bertrand burgala
bienvenue à vous vous êtes musicien
compositeur arrangeur et producteur on
vous a vu témoigner bien sûr dans ce
documentaire et pourquoi vous êtes celui
dont le livre a inspiré cette enquête
que nous venons de voir cet ouvrage
s'appelle diabétiquement votre il est
publié chez Kalman Levy vous êtes
diabétique de type 1 et dépendant à
l'insuline depuis maintenant 47 ans et
vous êtes le fondateur par ailleurs de
l'association diabète et méchant avec
nous également sur le bateau le
professeur Fabrice bonnet bienvenue vous
êtes
endocrinologue et diabetologue et auteur
de mieux vivre avec un diabète sans
réponse pour comprendre sa maladie et
mieux se soigner au quotidien publier
aux éditions Marabout ça c'est déjà une
bonne nouvelle après le documentaire que
nous venons de voir Pauline landaq c'est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuse et cofondatrice de
l'Observatoire de la transparence dans
la politique des médicaments et vous
êtes l'auteur avec Jérôme Martin de
combien coûte nos vies point
d'interrogation en quête sur les
politiques du médicament disponibles
chez UNIVERS POCHE une petite
cartographie qui résume quelques
chiffres avec une petite mise à jour de
ce déjà citer dans ce film que nous
venons de voir en 2021 le diabète alors
à la fois type 1 et type 2 en
augmentation régulière depuis 20 ans le
diabète touche aujourd'hui en France
environ 3,5 millions de personnes
quelques 537 millions de personnes dans
le monde et à cette allure une personne
sur dix pourrait être concernée dès 2045
la maladie fait deux millions de morts
par an sur notre planète je l'ai dit
vous êtes diabétique de type 1 en 47 ans
est-ce que les traitements auxquels vous
avez eu droit pour lutter contre ce
diabète de type 1 ont évolué et vous ont
un temps soit peu soulager la vie en 47
ans il y a eu des évolutions
ergonomiques qui sont indéniables les
stylos insulines il y a eu des capteurs
de glycémie maintenant qui est vraiment
améliore la vie quotidienne mais en
réalité il y a pas eu d'innovation
fondamentales depuis la découverte de
l'insuline pour le diabète de type
il y a pas eu d'innovations
fondamentales parce que
c'est une maladie qui est difficile à
traiter il suffit pas il y a pas eu une
assemblée de personnes qui ont décidé de
pas soigner de diabète mais diabète de
type 1 est une maladie auto-immune et
les industriels font des recherches mais
qui sont des recherches vraiment de en
général ils sortent une nouvelle
insuline quand le brevet de la
précédente va tomber dans le domaine
public donc c'est ce qu'on appelle des
mee-tout il y a des recherches comme ça
qui sont qui relèvent presque du
marketing mais la recherche fondamentale
elle est ardue je pense qu'elle viendra
plus donc de la recherche dans d'autres
domaines dans les autres maladies
auto-immunes et ce qui rend il y a une
forme de paresse intellectuelle en
revanche c'est dans la diabétologie
parce que c'est une maladie qui rapporte
tellement d'argent que c'est très
compliqué de chercher des innovations de
rupture après vous avez beaucoup
d'argent qui investit
un peu parfois c'est des concours
d'éloquence vous avez des sociétés en
France comme diabello qui ont perçu
énormément d'argent pour des pour des
capteurs connectés ou des choses comme
ça mais voilà sur le diabète de type 1
le diabète de type 2 c'est une maladie
de société et qui est
présentée comme tel dans ce documentaire
j'imagine que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
moi j'ai une question toute bête à vous
propose à vous poser professeur alors
diabète type 1 10% entre 5 et 10% des
diabétiques aujourd'hui dans le monde
mais qui dépendent à 100% de l'insuline
pourquoi on n'a pas encore trouvé un
médicament miracle pour lutter contre le
contrôle diabète et a commencé par ce
fameux diabète de type 1 qu'est-ce qui
explique que qu'on n'est pas trouvé ce
médicament et parallèlement on assiste à
une progression grandissante de cette
maladie à la à la fois en France bien
sûr mais on le verra tout à l'heure
sur l'ensemble de la planète c'est parce
que c'est la recherche n'est pas facile
il faut remplacer l'insuline qui n'est
plus sécrétée par le pancréas des
patients dans le petit pain c'est des
cellules qui ne se répliquent pas qui ne
se renouvellent pas comme des neurones
qu'on a perdu donc on espère les
cellules souches mais c'est pas si
simple vous savez on part de cellules
fœtale donc il y a quand même donc c'est
comme une recherche compliquée c'est pas
uniquement une mauvaise un mauvais
vouloir des scientifiques et des
chercheurs tellement compliqué qu'on n'a
pas trouvé et l'insuline peut pas se
prendre en comprimé elle est dégradée
elle s'injecte on espère avoir une
insuline une fois par semaine mais donc
on améliore un peu la galénique et les
techniques d'injection c'est vrai et
c'est important de l'entendre aussi le
retour de de nos patients mais le
médicament miracle du type 1 il est pas
encore là et c'est vraiment donné plus
de confort aux patient mais on n'a pas
trouvé la solution miracle je pense
qu'on pourra peut-être trouver un moment
donné à peut-être régénérer ces cellules
qui sécrètent l'insuline c'est plus
facile dans le type 2 alors le type 2
c'est aussi l'écrasante majorité donc
c'est vrai que les moyens vont peut-être
plus dans le type de que dans le petit
pain parce que c'est 95 des diabétiques
et c'est ce ces diabétiques là aussi qui
augmentent énormément ils augmentent
énormément parce qu'on mange mal on
prend du poids et on essaie dentaire
c'est cette fameuse maladie du siècle
c'est plutôt ce diabète de type 2
qui est à notre système de consommation
qui a émergé depuis maintenant tout à
fait il y a sédentarité et malbouffe
pour le dire un peu mais c'est et qui
favorise l'obésité le surpoids et le
diabète on va voir un extrait du
documentaire je vous donne la parole
bien sûr juste après le prix s'est
explosion des prix et l'accessibilité à
l'insuline ça c'est le problème majeur
qui met en avant dans ce film
aux États-Unis cette oligopole a abouti
à une situation
ubuesque et tragique
en disant le prix de l'insuline a été
multiplié par 10 alors qu'un dixième de
la population est diabétique certains
malades ne peuvent plus se payer cette
hormone vitale
même en souscrivant des assurances
privées hors de prix
alors l'oligopole dont il est question
il est constitué majoritairement de
trois laboratoires on va bien sûr citer
leur nom le Danois nouveau nordiste 13
milliards de dollars de vente en 2016 ce
chiffre date un peu mais c'est toujours
le premier laboratoire parmi le français
Sanofi et les Américains Lily on a cité
dans ce documentaire et accessoirement
MSD qui était aussi un autre acteur
oligopole ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire c'est très peu de société qui
détiennent entre leurs mains le marché
de l'insuline et des médicaments pour
lutter contre contre le diabète comment
on explique cette explosion des prix et
ce déficit d'accès à la à la matière
première pour soigner les patients
qu'elle l'insuline alors vous l'avez
très bien résumé il y a trois films qui
se partagent 80% du marché mondial
d'insuline ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
même si il n'y a pas qu'un seul
producteur mais trois il n'y a pas
suffisamment de producteurs pour qu'ils
ne réel compétition et pour que y ait
des prix en revue à la en tout cas plus
plus proche des réels coût de production
qui sont d'ailleurs évoqués dans le film
et qui sont beaucoup plus bas que les
prix de vente j'ai vu que c'est 5
dollars un flacon d'insuline 5 dollars à
fabriquer mais même ça c'est pas plus
des estimations c'est des estimations
hautes en réalité c'est encore plus bas
que ça encore plus bas pourquoi parce
que en fait on a on nous c'est ce qu'on
constate de le travail de l'Observatoire
de la transparence c'est de voir que
justement il y a très peu de
transparence dans la fixation du prix
des médicaments c'est à dire que les
pouvoirs publics ne sont pas non pas en
main tous les critères rationnels au
moment de la fixation des prix qui leur
permettent de voir le coût de production
les investissements qui ont été faits en
recherche et développement pour estimer
si la demande d'un prix d'un fabricant
est justifié ou non et par ailleurs le
fait qu'il y ait que trois gros
producteurs principalement ça limite
vraiment le pouvoir de négociation des
états c'est-à-dire que ils sont
dépendants de ces trois firmes et donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui en 32 100
ans après la découverte de l'insuline à
l'Université de Toronto et bien
seulement 50% de la population mondiale
il y a accès
ce qui est très un diabétique sur deux
dans le monde ne peut avoir accès
exactement un diabétique un suivi au
dépendant pour qui donc l'insuline est
un produit vital si on n'a pas
d'insuline on meurt assez rapidement
il n'y a pas accès c'est une question
qui transcende tous les clivages parce
que on peut pas mettre ça sur le
libéralisme l'étatisme puisque
on est dans un on est dans du
capitalisme de connivence donc c'est on
a à la fois le pire de l'étatisme mais
le pire de
libéralisme c'était un libéralisme sans
sans libre concurrence en gros on a
trois laboratoires dans le monde qui se
partagent un gâteau de 47 47 milliards
de d'euros et moi ce qui a été le point
de départ de ma de ma démarche je suis
devenu diabétique à 11 ans 75 et le
premier déclic que j'ai eu c'est quand
il y a eu sans contaminé
quand il y a eu l'affaire du centre
contaminé qui a été mise au grand jour
grâce à Anne-Marie casterey Jean
peron-gard vanhov qui était
l'association des polytransfusées il y
avait tout d'un coup j'ai vu il faut pas
dire tout à coup tout d'un coup
aujourd'hui mais c'est un mot qu'on
utilise mais immédiatement j'ai vu que
c'était exactement le même contexte
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait aucune
séparation des pouvoirs entre les
associations de patients les médecins
les industriels et les autorités de
santé et à partir de là
nous-mêmes patients pouvons être
instrumentalisés on nous pousse à
demander certains traitements et c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant parce que
vous avez des personnes qui vont dire il
faut il faut une santé publique forte
etc mais qui en réalité quand on regarde
deviennent enfin servent des intérêts
qui sont des intérêts privés il y a un
exemple absolument vous le connaissez
bien c'est l'entus puisque vous l'avez
utilisé c'est ce que vous dites dans ce
documentaire l'anti c'est le produit
phare de ça aussi ça a été le produit
star qui a rapporté des milliards et des
milliards d'euros à
avant que ce brevette tombe
en 2015 donc ce produit ne vous a
apporté aucune amélioration non ça a été
un coup de génie du marketing de Sanofi
c'est qu'ils ont fait croire que c'était
la seule insuline qui couvrait 24 heures
quand je suis devenu diabétique on
faisait une picole insuline par jour
donc il doit y avoir un problème mais
elle avait des elle avait des avantages
et des inconvénients comme un nouveau
produit je dis pas du tout je mets de
prise pas du tout Sanofi là-dessus enfin
l'aventus mais ils ont réussi à obtenir
un remboursement et qui a été le début
de cette course au prix parce qu'ils
sont rendus compte qu'il suffisait pour
gonfler leur chiffre d'affaires de
monter le prix de l'aventus et c'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui à la fois ça
c'est terrible pour les pays même pour
des pays riches puisque le diabète
représente 20% des dépenses de santé
dans un pays comme la France hors covid
mais dans des pays même comme les
États-Unis il y a des statues et dans
tous les pays d'Afrique subsaharienne
pays du tiers-monde il y a pas de
diabétique comme moi il meurt avant
qu'on les détecte
comme ça
20% des patients d'un diabète de type 1
qui arrête leur insuline
mais en revanche quand vous dites ça
c'est un peu cruel mais est-ce que vous
avez normalement vous savez qu'il y a la
loi HPST 2010 qui oblige les praticiens
qui est ce qui s'exprime publiquement
sur des questions comme ça comme sur
l'aventus de dire s'ils ont des liens
d'intérêt avec avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique est-ce que vous en avez
professeur sûr oui mais vous vous
trouvez pas un médecin qui qui n'a pas
enfin c'est très rare de trouver des
médecins qui n'a pas travaillé avec
parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'on fait
pas de recherche qu'on qu'on puisse
sur le sujet ils sont déclarés oui il y
en a un peu plus dans le type 2 dans les
mais non mais ce que je voulais dire par
là c'était que il y a aussi tout le
problème de l'observance des traitements
des de ces nombreux comprimés que
doivent prendre les patients et du fait
que et c'est un coup d'ailleurs pour la
société des traitements qui ne servent à
rien qui ne sont pas pris c'est un réel
problème là-dessus
je vous retrouve très condescendant
parce que ce mot même d'observance il y
a une infantilisation des patients en
particulier des diabétiques de type 2 ok
on explique qui sont mal conduits qui
mangent des mauvaises choses et on leur
donne souvent des recommandations y
compris des autorités de santé mondiale
sont totalement erronées c'est on leur
dit manger des jus de fruits bio et des
bananes parce que c'est effectivement
toute la fin du film qu'on vient de voir
mais ce qui est terrible dans le diabète
et le professeur bonnet est vraiment
quelqu'un de très très intéressant qui
dit des choses vraiment tout à fait
raisonnables mais ce qui est compliqué
avec le diabète c'est qu'il y a une
culpabilisation des malades y compris
les diabétiques de type 1 qui est pour
qui ça arrive comme une météorite qui
leur tombe dessus mais toute la
pédagogie une pédagogie noire sur les
diabétiques qui les décourage et c'est
ce qui fait que beaucoup de diabétiques
lâchent y compris des diabétiques de
type 1 qui font moi j'ai fait pendant
des années quand j'étais adolescent je
faisais une piqûre de piqûres par jour
et je faisais n'importe quoi et c'est
très très dangereux
oui moi je voulais revenir sur sur ce
qui a été dit sur le fait que le prix
des médicaments soit indolore en France
d'une certaine façon pour les pour les
patients pour les personnes la réalité
c'est qu'en fait on paye le prix des
médicaments et on paye les augmentations
parce qu'on est dans une dynamique
d'augmentation du prix des médicaments
un peu incontrôlés pas justifié par des
critères rationnels depuis 2014 et le
souci c'est qu'on le paye on le paye
quand on va aux urgences et qu'on a plus
accès au service d'urgence parce qu'il
n'y a plus de moyens on le paye quand on
va à l'hôpital on paye quand il faut
attendre trois mois pour voir un
spécialiste donc c'est faux de dire que
on ne le paye pas vraiment c'est
invisibilisé mais en réalité on paye et
le problème c'est que si demain des
découvertes majeures ont lieu sur le
diabète à quel prix ce sera c'est-à-dire
à quel prix ce sera vendu par les firmes
pharmaceutiques à la société c'est pour
ça que nous on préconise vraiment de
réinjecter du rationnel dans les
politiques du médicament en ayant des
critères pour fixer les prix des
médicaments de façon un peu plus
raisonnable alors il existe aussi des
insulines génériques on peut les appeler
comme ça ce les insuline bio similaires
voilà comme ça on les appelle sont des
génériques les brevets sont tombés dans
le domaine public et effectivement l'OMS
d'ailleurs compte beaucoup sur ces
insulines
génériques pour développer l'accès à
l'insuline sur les continents ou c'est
particulièrement délicat alors on pense
à notamment à l'Afrique et à l'Asie par
exemple aujourd'hui c'est une piste
intéressante pour baisser le prix et
est-ce que les laboratoires qu'on a cité
tout à l'heure vont jouer le jeu la
production de BIOS similaire est
vraiment une question essentielle en
revanche pour l'insuline ça pose il y a
différents paramètres en matière de
production à avoir en tête c'est à dire
qu'il faut des capacités de production
assez importantes pour avoir une
économie d'échelle intéressante c'est
quand même voilà c'est une des
particularités de la production
d'insuline ce qui veut dire là où je
vais revenir c'est que c'est plus
compliqué mais toutes les difficultés du
monde aujourd'hui à trouver les
fabricants pour fabriquer cette pour
rentrer sur un marché il faut avoir un
il faut pouvoir proposer un produit à
pour essayer de sanitaire qui
remplissent toutes les contraintes
réglementaires de sécurité etc et il
faut pouvoir proposer un prix plus bas
dès le départ de ce qui existe déjà donc
ça crée déjà c'est difficile pour un
quatrième 5e 6e producteur d'arriver
face à ces trois firmes qui sont
aujourd'hui bien implantés dans la
plupart des pays et du coup c'est pour
ça que l'OMS pour répondre complètement
à votre question a mis en place un
système de préqualification sur les bio
similaires d'insuline mais aujourd'hui
elle a un petit peu de mal pour le
moment à avoir des candidats vous
prescrivez ce type de BIOS similaires
oui oui parce que il y a des économies à
la clé notamment pour les établissements
moi je travaille en CHU il y a des
économies et donc et et c'est exactement
c'est le similaire de la lentille donc
oui oui bien sûr aux États-Unis
lorsqu'on a vu l'augmenter des prix le
nombre de personnes qui n'ont plus accès
et qui décèdent d'ailleurs des suites de
cette valise faute d'accès à cette
insuline c'est une solution
qui peut faire avancer les choses à
votre avis oui générique ce prix de
l'insuline est totalement injustifié
donc c'est une on l'a vu dans le
documentaire ça a été inventé il y a 100
ans il y a des innovations de temps en
temps mais ce qui ce qui est terrible
depuis le début c'est qu'on peut même
pas acheter l'ancien produit un peu
rustique et qui pourrait sauver plein de
vie partout donc cette inflation elle
est criminelle
il y a c'est un enjeu de diplomatie
sanitaire ça serait formidable que les
pouvoirs publics en France qui ont fait
depuis ce documentaire on a fait
progresser certaines choses
l'Assemblée avait
voté en décembre
2021 c'était Agnès Firmin le Baudot qui
était à l'origine d'une proposition de
loi pour l'accès des personnes
diabétiques au monde du travail qui a
été très très bien conçu qui fait
vraiment avancer chose on s'est
rapprochés nous diabète et méchants de
roses pour l'accès à lassurance et grâce
à cette association pour le cancer on a
fait un d'autres vilains petits canards
comme ça d'associations de patients et
on a réussi à faire changer la loi le
questionnaire de santé qui maintenant
est supprimé pour les prêts immobiliers
jusqu'à 200000 euros par quotité il
reste beaucoup comme quoi avec du
volontarisme politique on peut peut-être
arriver absolument à enlever les choses
il y a quelque chose pour la France qui
pourrait être formidable c'est un enjeu
mondial je pense que le chef d'État qui
aujourd'hui portera la question du prix
de l'insuline aux Nations Unies orales
prix Nobel un jour ou l'autre en tout
cas ça tout est en tout cas ça sera
mérité parce qu'on ne se rend pas compte
c'est une maladie qui ne se voit pas on
l'a dit mais on ne se rend pas compte
aujourd'hui des morts et des drames qui
sont causés d'une façon qui est
injustifiable c'est-à-dire qu'on est
avec des marges de 3000%. et puis le
gouvernement lui aussi s'est interrogé
un sur ces hausses de prix et on a vu
que il est les trois laboratoires
nouveau Nord disques Sanofi et Lily ont
dû passer devant une commission et suite
à ces auditions et bien ils ont été
contraints malgré tout baisser le prix
de l'insuline pour
un certain type de population les plus
les plus démunis c'est ce qu'il dit dans
dans ce film vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose non mais c'est vrai je
pense pour les personnes qui
connaissent pas très bien forcément la
situation des États-Unis il faut
imaginer que aujourd'hui il y a des
familles aux États-Unis des parents qui
rationnent qui partagent leur dose
quotidienne d'insuline avec leurs
enfants parce que les enfants n'ont une
fois qu'ils ont grandi qui quittent le
domicile etc familial non plus accès et
ça je pense que c'est vraiment enfin
c'est vraiment un échec du système de
santé d'arriver à ça pour quelque chose
qui a été découvert il y a 100 ans du
système de santé américain bien sûr
celui dont vous parlez on va voir un
deuxième extrait et ensuite je vais vers
vous sur les alternatives possibles à
défaut d'avoir un médicament miracle
peut-être que si on s'alimente mieux si
on vit si notre hygiène de vie est plus
saine et bien on peut arriver à réduire
le nombre de diabétiques de type 2 c'est
en tout cas ce qui est dit dans ce
documentaire
dans le diabète de type 2 on a longtemps
cru qu'une fois qu'on avait le diabète
on l'avait à vie
un jour un groupe de chercheurs anglais
a réalisé une étude sensationnelle ils
ont pris des personnes qui avaient un
diabète depuis quelques années leur ont
fait perdre beaucoup de poids et ont pu
démontrer que 50 à 80% d'entre eux selon
le poids qu'il perdait parvenait à une
rémission du diabète sans aucune
opération juste par une perte de poids
radical alors professeur là on a envie
de se dire tout ça pour ça on pourrait
réduire un tiers des diabétiques de type
2 si l'origine de vie était meilleure si
leurs habitudes de consommation en
matière d'alimentation étaient meilleurs
c'est ce que nous dit votre confrère
allemande dans ce film oui c'est c'est
globalement vrai alors il dit c'est des
diabètes récents pas des diabètes avec
15 ans de parce que le vecteur rage est
important attention à pas culpabiliser
tous les patients parce qu'on pourrait
dire à ce moment-là vous êtes diabétique
vous l'avez cherché bien écoutez on va
pas rembourser vous avez qu'à maigrir il
faut savoir que parfois ça a été une
politique aussi de dire un médicament
dans le diabète finalement ils ont qu'à
mieux manger et puis et on peut dire
d'un certain côté c'est pas complètement
faux mais vous voyez en même temps il y
a des trajectoires très différents il y
a des patients qui ont une maladie du
pancréas qui fait qu'il devienne
diabétiques et c'est pas parce qu'ils
ont péché parce qu'ils ont mangé de
manière inappropriée en excès et puis
pour d'autres c'est vrai donc il y a
effectivement des notions diététiques
mais vous voyez et on sait aussi que le
diabète de type 2 touche des populations
de catégories sociales plus précaires
plus défavorisées on touche plus c'est
c'est populations là donc c'est la
malbouffe c'est compliqué il y a de
l'éducation de l'éducation à l'école de
l'éducation pour sensibiliser à une
meilleure alimentation donc il y a des
progrès bouger davantage tout ça et on
peut prévenir le diabète ça c'est un
message FA après attention on peut pas
dire que il y a une période qu'on
appelle prédiabétique si j'ai bien
compris tu peux durer entre 5 et on peut
à ce moment-là s'alerté de manière
positive pour éviter d'aller vers le
diabète mais en revanche ce que dit
votre conflit allemand c'est à dire que
des patients souffrant d'un diabète de
type 2 s'il restreint
et change ses habitudes alimentaires
s'il fait du sport et c'est surtout sur
l'aspect alimentaire que porte son
intervention notamment c'est ce qui se
passe pour les patients qui sont opérés
d'une chirurgie de l'obésité qui perd 30
kilos et là on parle de rémission du
diabète parce qu'il y a une perte de
poids importante mais on peut aussi s'en
chirurgie avant une perte de poids
importante mais c'est plus rare en
pratique
je pense que bon vous avez vous avez
d'idées énormément de choses là dessus
mais vraiment il faut pas oublier non
plus qu'il y a vraiment une augmentation
de la malnutrition c'est difficile de
bien se nourrir aussi donc il y a une
culte il faut attention à la
culpabilisation parce que les
populations plus elles sont précaires
plus c'est compliquées d'avoir accès à
de la nourriture à se nourrir de la
façon la façon la plus équilibrée donc
ça je pense que c'est essentiel d'avoir
ça en tête quand on regarde par exemple
l'épidémiologie le diabète en Afrique on
voit qu'il y a une vraie corrélation
entre l'augmentation aujourd'hui très
importante sur le continent africain du
diabète et les comportements
alimentaires où on est passé de la
sous-nutrition à une malnutrition où on
mélange un peu tout du sucre du sucre
et en Chine là c'est c'est effectivement
très sensible en Chine oui c'est il faut
qu'on fasse très attention parce que ces
deux maladies tellement différentes
quand on parle là de quand on parle de
rémission c'est c'est le diabète de type
2 sur le type 1 malheureusement ça
n'existe pas et c'est vraiment deux
maladies qui devraient avoir en réalité
deux noms différents parce que c'est pas
du tout les mêmes enjeux ni économiques
ni socio ni en termes de recherche le
diabète de type 2 n'attend pas un
médicament miracle alors que le typain
c'est vraiment quelque chose de crucial
donc c'est c'est très important de bien
de bien distinguer ces pénible mais il
faut vraiment distinguer ces deux
maladies dans l'intérêt des diabétiques
de type 2 et dans l'intérêt des types
parce que les diabétiques de type 2 on
leur fait peser une fatalité une
culpabilisation énorme et les typains on
nous dit il y a toujours enfin c'était
terrible on dit je suis diabétique ah
oui j'ai un oncle diabétique etc enfin y
est et c'est très difficile pour les
diabétiques de type 1 par exemple dans
la vie courante à la fois on peut vivre
comme tout le monde mais pour se faire
accepter on doit on est souvent obligé
de minorer mais des difficultés du
diabète
donc c'est très important que les
diabétiques puissent travailler
parce que c'est compliqué de travailler
à une caisse de supermarché des
diabétiques de devoir faire des piqûres
etc et donc pour parfois pour se faire
accepter on est obligé de minorer ça et
c'est important de le dire un diabétique
peut faire beaucoup de choses mais c'est
pas facile pour lui c'est bien c'est
bien que l'entourage puisse le
comprendre en tant que que malade du
diabète de type 1 est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas tous les efforts partent
maintenant sur le diabète de type 2 au
détriment des malades
il s'est passé là-dessus on a par
exemple le succès de la lentille
s'effectivement ça a été aussi ça c'est
qu'on a détourné une insuline on est en
train de mettre le plus de plus en plus
de diabétiques insuline et parfois de
façon justifiée mais ça a été montré
dans le documentaire on a aussi baissé
les normes donc tout le monde devient un
diabétique en puissance
passé un certain âge il suffit de dire
c'est plus un gramme 30 mais un gramme
26 vous avez des millions de diabétiques
supplémentaires dans le donc c'est
l'hypocrisie de tout ça c'est que vous
avez des personnes qui prennent un air
Terry terrifié qu'ils ont c'est affreux
il y a de plus en plus de diabétiques
puis vous regardez dans les pages éco
les mêmes disent c'est formidable on a
des perspectives de croissance géniales
et moi je fais très attention de pas
être manichéen je dis jamais les
multinationales jamais Big Pharma on a
un besoin d'une industrie pharmaceutique
on a besoin d'insuline c'est très
important y compris de l'anthus ou de
choses comme ça c'est pas du tout on
n'est pas
parce que souvent c'est un procès
d'intention qu'on nous fait la médecine
du futur les grèves de pancré a par
exemple ça se fait de
l'automatisation oui l'automatisation
les nouvelles technologies ont évoluer
et est-ce qu'il y a des de réaliser des
espoirs oui pour améliorer la qualité de
vie du patient parfois un petit peu
aussi l'équilibre notamment moins
d'hypoglycémie il y a les pompes
insulines que nous avons la chance
d'avoir remboursé en France ce qui n'est
pas le cas dans d'autres pays y compris
dans le type 2 où on est presque une
exception
c'est bon les pompes insulines
maintenant deviennent très miniatures
miniaturisé et automatique c'est ce
qu'on appelle le circuit hybride ou la
boucle fermée c'est-à-dire que elle va
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle
calculer elle-même la dose d'insuline au
cours de la journée et s'adapter au mode
de vie du patient alors c'est formidable
il y a un engouement chez beaucoup de
diabétiques de type 1 mais tous les
diabétiques de type 1 n'aiment pas la
pompe déjà et le prix est scandaleux
parce que c'est
30 fois ce que un diabétique dès si je
demande à mon diabétologue une pompe si
j'aille voir mon diabétologie je me sens
pas très bien il y a une chance sur deux
qui me disent pourquoi vous n'êtes pas à
pompe insuline et là mon traitement est
multiplié par 30 et c'est encore une
fois c'est l'absence de contre-pouvoir
c'est l'absence de de de
décision collective et de du comité
d'économique des produits de santé qui
fait pas son travail
les greffes les greffes oui mais il y a
des traitements immunosuppresseurs qui
ont des effets indésirables donc c'est
encore compliqué les cellules souches et
les grèves c'est une source d'espoir
mais on n'est pas encore c'est pas
encore complètement maîtrisé ou
applicable à l'ensemble des diabétiques
mais quand même je voudrais garder une
note d'espoir pour l'avenir des patients
un jeune diabétique je pense que au
cours de sa ville va voir des
innovations et je le crois alors c'est
une croyance c'est un espoir mais il y
aura des innovations au-delà de
simplement des nouveaux stylos je
l'espère fortement mais je pense aussi
parce que c'est un marché colossal c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
circulent mais je pense que et c'est ce
que je peux espérer en tant que soignant
et bien ça revienne sur la qualité du
soin et la qualité de vie pour le
patient alors sur ces nouvelles
approches ces approches qu'on va
qualifier du futur est-ce qu'on retrouve
les mêmes intervenants les mêmes
laboratoires dont on a parlé dans cette
émission ou ce sont de nouveaux acteurs
qui vont intervenir sur ce marché avec
les cris avec peut-être les mêmes
dérives au niveau des des prix vous
l'avez évoqué là aussi on a à une
alimentation considérable des prix
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire de nouveaux
acteurs qui vont intervenir sur le
marché là alors il y a fort à parier que
ce sera les mêmes acteurs qui vont
continuer à continuer à chercher sur sur
le diabète mais il y a également en fait
ce qu'on a ce à quoi on assise depuis
une vingtaine d'années c'est une
financièreisation de la recherche ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
multinationales ont extériorisé ou
externalisés de plus en plus les la
recherche et développement donc souvent
ce qu'elles font c'est qu'elles
identifient les petites startups qui
elles ont mis la main sur des des
candidats candidats traitement et des
diagnostics des outils de suivi etc qui
sont prometteurs et ensuite qu'elle les
rachète et qu'elle parient en fait sur
sur le développement de ces de ces
produits ou de ces dispositifs médicaux
ça sera le mot de la fin vraiment un
grand merci à tous les trois devoir
participé à ce débat docs aujourd'hui
Bertrand burgala on va rappeler que le
documentaire que nous avons vu et tirer
de diabétiquement votre livre publié
chez chez Calmon Levy vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des badogs sur Twitter
je compte sur vous tous les trois pour
réagir à ce que sont ces réactions et à
mon avis elle risque d'être très
nombreuses merci aussi à sel massali qui
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission comme
à la coutumée puis je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
ça sera bien sûr avec son documentaire
et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]